>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, D.C.
>> So now it is my sincere pleasure to introduce
Lee Ann Potter, who will be speaking to you
about what's new from the Library of Congress.
A little bit about Lee Ann.
She leads a dynamic team, committed
to developing educational programs
and materials based on primary sources.
Before coming to the library, she created
and directed education and volunteer programs
at the National Archives in
Washington, D.C. for 16 years.
Prior to that, Lee Ann worked
at the Smithsonian on a project
to build museum-school partnerships.
And before that, she was a high
school social studies teacher.
She has conducted hundreds of
presentations and is the author
of numerous articles promoting
teaching with primary sources.
Lee Ann, thank you so much.
>> Thanks so much.
And Cheryl, I have to say I love
it when you use that introduction
and you indicate I lead a dynamic team,
knowing full well that you are
absolutely a part of that dynamic team.
So thanks for the introduction.
And to all of you, thanks
so much for being here.
I especially appreciate those of you
who have spent the entire day teaching
and have made a commitment to your own
professional development in the evening.
You rock, and your students ought to know that.
So welcome to what's new
at the Library of Congress.
As Cheryl said, I'm Lee Ann.
I direct educational outreach at the library,
and I'm really excited to have this opportunity
to give you a little sneak peek into some
things that are new at the library and resources
that will soon be coming your way.
To get the ball rolling and to make
sure that the chat function is working,
which I obviously see that it is, because
now I know where you are all sitting.
I hope you are all in your slippers, by the way.
I'd like you to use the chat function,
and a few of you could just chime
and tell m what the word "new" means to you.
When I say "new."
[laughter] Rachel, it's great,
because you're in your robe.
I've got my slippers on, I have to admit.
When I think of the word "new," mostly
what I think of is what you had in mind.
I think of new and improved, and new
and different, new meaning unusual
or not existing before, or recently
discovered, or just beginning.
And I suspect that your interest in this
session had something to do with the word "new."
We all do seem to like things that are new, and
there is a lot of talk about things that are new
or just beginning, in terms of
things going on at the library.
Resources, programs, and more.
And in the next 40 minutes, I plan to
tell you about a wide variety of them.
Got a couple of objectives tonight.
I'd like to spend some time describing the
teaching with primary sources philosophy.
How do you participate in a
primary source analysis activity?
Identify some new materials, and describe
some new programs and collaborations.
And my real hope is that you won't just
keep them to yourself, but you'll share them
with others during and after the session.
I know many of you are already familiar with
the teaching the primary sources philosophy.
But in a nutshell, we at the library believe
that primary sources are
powerful teaching tools.
They can inspire, fascinate, and engage
learners of all ages in every subject,
and I'm going to show you some of that tonight.
So you have to put your thinking caps on.
I'm going to show you a very interesting
source from the library's collection.
I went to the library's website,
and as I was thinking
about this session, I simply
typed in "what's new?"
And what came up was this source, and I thought
you'd spend a little bit of time looking at it,
focus your attention on it
for a couple of minutes.
And if you could indicate, or in the chat there
type what you observe, what you think this is.
If you'd indicate what you see,
what you think, and what you wonder.
That probably sounds familiar to those of
you who've worked with the library before.
I could just as easily ask you to
observe, reflect, and question.
And I've got a really good reason
for sharing this one with you.
Yes, Kristen, you're right.
It is a cover page to some sheet music.
Matt wants to go dancing.
This is great.
Musical piece in three-quarter time, love it.
Turn of the century.
Ah, I love this.
What makes you think it's
the turn of the century?
I'm just curious.
Is it the font, or can you read the fine print?
Good, there you go.
You guys are good.
And by the way, everything on all my
slides, I have hyperlinked everything.
So if you start clicking, you will end
up, you know, with the sources themselves.
And know that this session is being recorded,
so you can certainly go back to
it and poke around some more.
I'm scanning the chat.
These are great.
So here's that primary source analysis
tool that I was making reference
to that's available on the library's website.
For those of you who are not familiar with
it, questions about observing and reflecting
and questioning are on the sheet and really
does serve as a nice way for students
who are just getting used to working with
primary sources to focus their attention.
Let me tell you a little bit about this.
So here's the bibliographic record for
that piece of sheet music, and from it,
we do learn that it is a piece of sheet
music, and it was published at the tail end
of the 1800s, and it was published
by a company in Philadelphia.
But when you look at this
particular bibliographic record,
there's a section I want you to note, and it's
right over here in this little area over here.
It says that it's part of
a particular collection,
and it says that it is part
of the "Songs of America.
I'm wondering if any of you have poked
around the "Songs of America" collection.
I want to tell you about it.
It launched about a year ago, and it
is truly a treasure trove of resources.
In addition to sheet music like this one,
there are also recordings and short videos
that feature curators from the library.
As the site says, it allows you to see
and hear American history through song.
And like I said, if any of you have
explored the "Songs of America," I'd love you
to indicate in the chat what you found.
My favorite item in the "Songs
of America" site falls
under a section called Articles
and Essays, right in this area.
There are these curator talks that I mentioned.
They last about five minutes long.
They're videos that highlight special
items that are in the collection,
and a couple of illustrated
songs are also there.
One of those illustrated songs, what
they've done is they've taken a recording,
and they have augmented it with images of
sources from across the library's collection.
One that they have done is sort
of a sample, features a recording
of a song about the Titanic disaster.
And like I said, it's accompanied by
related items from the library's collection.
It's really a great model of an
activity you might have students do.
You know, I have a 12-year-old at
home, and she loves making movies.
And I keep thinking, "Oh, I gotta
have her do one, just as an example,
in the same vein as what they've done in
'Songs of America.'" It's really clever.
I think you will enjoy that.
I encourage you to poke around there,
and see what else you can find.
During our Summer Teacher Institute
this past summer, we hold an open house,
and during the open house, colleagues
from across the library are invited
to meet our teachers, and share
ideas and resources with them.
The room is set up almost like an exhibit space,
and we do assign teachers a particular table
to start their exploration at, so that
participants are evenly distributed,
and all of our colleagues, you know,
have somebody to talk to from the get-go.
The teachers eventually do move around the
whole room, and each day of the institute,
we ask participants to complete an exit card
that describes a highlight of their day.
This image, this drawing here,
it's a little index card.
Imagine it being a little,
you know, three-by-five card.
It was drawn by one of our teachers, one of our
science teachers last year, describing a change
of heart that she experienced when she met
one of our colleagues from the music division
who told her about the Songs of America site.
Note on the left, she says, "Silly
Kate," before she meets this guy.
And she says, "My sheet says
to start at performing arts.
Oh, I love music.
Musical theater, dance, film, all
that, but I'm just going to smile,
till I get to go to a real table,"
and then of course she meets James,
and James tells her about "Songs of America."
And it occurs to her, "Duh, of course.
Music fits everywhere.
That's why I love it."
And then she describes herself again as
smaller headed, less condescending Kate
after having chatted with the guy
from music, and I just love it.
It's -- how many of you already are using music
in your classrooms and finding great success?
I hope many of you are.
Scanning the chat area.
These are great.
Cheryl, thanks for including
[inaudible] including the links.
These are great.
Good observations, yeah.
Awesome.
All right.
So I wanted to start this
session with the What's New?
[inaudible] sheet music, not only to tell
you about the "Songs of America" collection,
but also they tell you about an effort involving
the library's educational outreach team
and a few of the professional
organizations that serve teachers.
We recently began writing a regular feature
in the journals of the National Association
for Music Education, the National
Council for the Social Studies,
and the National Science Teachers Association.
You're also writing periodically for other
publications, including Cobblestone Magazine,
which is published by Cricket Media.
The National History Day Teacher's Guide.
You may have seen some of our
materials, as well as materials
that are supporting the NCSS C3 framework.
I hope you've noticed some of these
articles, and I am also curious
if there are other journals
we ought to be writing for.
Are any of you subscribing to other journals or
are members of other professional associations,
and you think, "Oh, the library absolutely needs
to have a presence amongst
some of these other resources"?
Outstanding.
Again, scanning this chat area.
Stephanie, I'm delighted
that you're participating.
I am anxious to hear what you
think of "Songs of America."
All right.
A couple of minutes ago, when we were
looking at this piece of sheet music,
I asked you to observe, reflect, and
question, and you may have noticed
that I also asked you what do you see,
what do you think, and what do you wonder?
My team has been working on some
new primary source analysis tools.
One of them is specifically
for very young students.
We've been doing some pilot
testing with kindergarteners
through second graders using both
these words, the "what do you see?
What do you think?
What do you wonder?"
as well as related icons.
And I'm not sure if up here on the
top right-hand side of my slide,
if you can really see this, but these
are some of the icons we were trying
out with the five-year-olds, to ask them when
they see images, what do they mean to them.
And we were pretty happy that "think"
was something that came to their minds.
We've also just drafted an article about
this pilot testing for the NCSS journal,
"Social Studies and the Young Learner."
We absolutely do believe that primary
sources are powerful teaching tools
across the grade spectrum.
Oh, good. I'm glad that -- good.
Thanks, Pete.
Very good.
We also just released a new primary source --
another primary source analysis tool
specifically focused on analyzing newspapers.
Again, the links are hot, so if you click
on it, you'll end up on the teacher's page,
and you'll see the teacher's guide
as well as the student iteration.
Speaking of newspapers, we came out
with the analysis tool just in time
for Chronicling America to
celebrate its one millionth page.
Many of you already familiar
with Chronicling America.
It is really an amazing website that is
supported by both the Library of Congress
and the National Endowment for the Humanities.
What's new with Chronicling America is that
the site did just post its ten millionth page,
and on the site you can, like it says, you
can search America's historic newspaper pages
from 1836 to 1922, or use the U.S.
newspaper directory to find information
about American newspapers that were
published between 1690 and the present.
Cindy, I'm with you.
I love, love, love Chronicling America.
I encourage all of you to check out
tomorrow evening's 6:00 pm session
as part of our online conference.
It's entitled "Teaching with Historical
Newspapers," and it is being presented by one
of our colleagues who works
in the periodicals divisions
at the library, describing Chronicling America.
Just for fun, when I was preparing this, I
did a search on October 27th, today's date,
and stumbled on this complete Sunday
magazine of the New York Tribune,
featuring Mark Twain's autobiography.
I thought it was great.
Those of you who have used Chronicling,
and I'd love to hear your experiences.
If you want to chat in the type area
and describe some of the things that you
and your students have done,
that would be great.
Oh, and Rachel, thank you for the
suggestion about the school library journal.
Great suggestions.
I find Chronicling America to be just
extraordinary, and what's amazing is when you're
in Chronicling America, you can do full text
searches of what's in these historic newspapers.
And you can search on not only historical
events and famous people's names, but every now
and then -- I was going to family reunion
earlier this summer, and I did a search
on our family name and the location
where some ancestors have lived
and was really quite tickled to find some
pretty good information in these old newspapers
about family members, and
their travels, and so forth.
But the other day, I was in Chronicling America,
and in addition to the articles that we find
in the newspaper -- old newspapers have
terrific advertisements, as you know,
and they have fabulous cartoons and images,
and I was doing a search on children's books,
and I came across this ad from the Omaha
Daily V. Anybody out there in Nebraska?
[inaudible] Omaha newspaper,
December the 8th, 1912.
And one of the books that it was promoting
for little folks was a book
called "The Rocket Book."
And I know it's really small.
You probably can't see it here,
but in this little section.
The book called "The Rocket
Book" was being promoted.
And the reason I got all excited about
it is because "The Rocket Book" is
in the library's collection, and it has recently
been digitized, and it's available at read.gov,
a special section of the library's website
that is supported by the library's center
for the book, along with many
other classic children's books.
I see that a bunch of you are typing,
so I'm going to type for a minute.
The rest of you can write
down things about, "Oh, wow.
That's fabulous.
I didn't know there were children's books."
There you go.
Yes, digitized children's book.
How did I not know this?
I love it, Kristen.
And there's lots of them.
And not only are they available
through read.gov, they are also --
you got a new Library of
Congress presence on Pinterest,
and quite a few of the children's books
are also available through Pinterest,
and the formatting's a little bit different,
but the scans, of course, are the same.
Oh, I love this.
You guys are liking these children's books.
This is good.
So for -- we had a group of teachers at the
library a year ago April, and we had asked some
of our colleagues who work in cataloguing of
rare children's books to do a little display
for our teachers, to show them some of
these classic, rare children's books,
and the teachers got very
excited, and we did too.
And of course, we all felt a little
deflated when we learned that, you know,
we were having this great chance
to see these terrific objects.
But at that moment, they hadn't been digitized.
And so I'm really tickled that
we can really share with you
that these are now available,
and there are more on the way.
Yes, they are absolutely available to download.
Everything that the library is digitizing in
terms of the classic children's books are books
that are beyond copyright, so we don't have
to worry about any restrictions on them.
And we're also trying to find some
new ways to make them available.
I mentioned earlier that we've been doing
some writing for [inaudible] Magazine,
which is an implant of Cricket Media,
and Cricket Media has an app
that's available called Story Bug.
We've been having some great
conversations with them about getting some
of these children's books available through
that app so that folks can use them, you know,
the way we use electronic books, as opposed
to simply using them as scans on a website.
So be on the lookout for that.
We're hoping that that will
happen sooner rather than later.
Very good.
Again, scanning the chat here.
Are the books available?
Yes. Do they include illustrations
that may have been in these --
yes, they are all there, full scans.
They are absolutely the digital
images of every page of the book.
This is great.
Miriam, I'm glad you're going to share.
Awesome. Maybe we will revitalize some
of these fabulous children's books.
And I have to say, that "Rocket
Book" is really very clever.
You're going to love it.
So that can be your bedtime story tonight.
Hey, there's an idea, Cheryl.
You could start doing bedtime
stories for teachers on webinars.
Okay, speaking of ebooks and social
media channels, this past school year,
we published 12 free student discovery sets.
And these are ebooks available
through the iBook store.
They feature primary sources from the library's
collections that have all been included
in our popular primary source sets that
are on the library's teachers page.
So if you're already familiar with the primary
source sets, the student discovery sets are kind
of student iterations, and we know that a lot of
teachers were using the primary source sets in,
you know, some pretty tangible ways, where
teachers would download or print out the images
of the specific documents they
intended to share with their students.
And we got more and more requests for
resources for teachers who were teaching
in classrooms where tablets were being used.
So that's exactly what these ebooks are.
They are the same primary source sets,
only on the student discovery sets,
they don't include the teacher's guide.
So all they are are the documents that you
want your students to share and work with.
And we've added some functionality to the
ebooks that make them quite a bit interactive.
We've got a function where students
can annotate the primary sources.
They can also take notes on them, and
they can capture what they're doing
and email their notes back to their teachers.
We're very excited about these ebooks and fully
intend to be making more of them available.
Some of the titles include the Great
Depression, the Harlem Renaissance.
There's one on symbols of America.
The most popular one, I'm happy to
report, is the one on the Constitution.
And we do hope to make them available for
Android devices in the coming school year.
The reason we started with
the Apple platform was simply
because the Apple iBooks author software was
a free download that we could experiment with.
Currently, there are 12 of them available.
And if you just go on to the iBook
store and do a search on "Library
of Congress student discovery
set," all 12 of them will come up.
Earlier, I mentioned the library
now has a Pinterest account.
The library also supports
a bunch of Twitter feeds.
We have one especially for teachers, and
we hope that you are followers of ours.
Next month, we will be using Twitter for a game.
And I am really excited now that I see how
many of you are excited about children's books,
now I'm really excited to tell you about this,
because the game that we're playing
has to do with children's books.
So next month, the month of November,
the library's CYAC program --
and CYAC is one of those silly government
acronyms, but it stands for the Children
and Young Adult Cataloguing Program.
They will be celebrating their 50th anniversary,
and we want to draw attention
to some of their work.
By the way, these are the catalogers of
the library who write the annotations
for children's books that
appear on card catalogs.
So if you go to your library,
and you go onto your school --
into the card catalog, and you
identify a children's book,
the description in the children's
book -- or, excuse me.
The description on the card that describes the
children's book, that description was written
by one of our colleagues at the library
who works in this CYAC division.
So the game we're going to play on Twitter
is we're going to share the descriptions
of children's books, and we're
going to ask our followers to see
if they can guess the children's book.
So we're going to do two right now.
We're going to see how you do.
So I'm going to give you some examples.
You're going to have to type in your answer.
So here's the description.
Mr. and Mrs. Mallard proudly
return to their home
in the Boston public garden
with their eight offspring.
Yes, that book.
Multiple attendees are typing.
I love that.
Yay, Rachel.
"Make Way for Ducklings."
Alison, you got it.
Annette, you got it.
Rebecca, you got it.
I love this.
I have a feeling Carol's about to get it.
This is terrific.
Yes, "Make Way for Ducklings."
It was written by Robert
McCloskey and published in 1941.
All right, we got another one.
Again, the description written by
one of our colleagues at the library.
When a bus driver takes a break from his route,
a very unlikely volunteer
springs up to take his place.
Any guesses?
When a bus driver takes a break from his route,
a very unlikely volunteer
springs up to take his place.
Yes. Margaret and Annette.
[laughter] This is great.
What I love about this is those of us who've
had children in the last, you know, 20 years,
we know our children's books well, I think,
and we certainly have memories of them as well.
But "Don't Let the Pigeon Drive the Bus" is
truly a classic, written by Mo Willems in 2003.
And if you haven't read it,
I highly recommend it.
So how many of you are going
to play our Twitter game?
We're going to do it the first week in November.
This is great.
Cheryl, we're learning a
lot about our audience here.
I love this.
This is great.
Okay. And I'm going to keep going.
So we've been talking about ebooks and Twitter,
and now I can tell you a
little bit about YouTube.
The Library of Congress also
has a YouTube channel.
Some of the content, you may be familiar
with from the library's professional
development modules
on the teacher's page are
also now available on YouTube.
We are adding some curator talks,
like this one from a colleague of ours
in the geography and math division.
And after this session is over, I encourage
you to check out what Mike has to say.
I think you'll enjoy what he talks about in
a really interesting World War Two era map.
On the library's YouTube channel, you will
also find a great deal of content related
to a recent exhibition at the library
related to the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
And this reminds me of another new
resource on the library's website,
and that new resource is the
Civil Rights History Project.
And I'm going to pause for just a second,
because there's a lot going on over here
in the chat I want to make sure I'm not missing.
Oh, good. You guys are all
going to play the Twitter game.
I love it.
[laughter] I love -- Rebecca,
I kind of feel like you do.
I'm not -- I have to say we use Twitter
more for work than personal accounts.
This is great.
But Kristen, you're absolutely right.
It is a great place for professional
development.
Okay. And then Cheryl's telling me I've
only got, like, 12 minutes to talk,
so I'm going to have to speed up, I guess.
Okay, this is great.
Okay, so the Civil Rights History Project.
It features oral histories of
individuals who were involved
with the Civil Rights Movement during
the 1950s and '60s in the United States.
Colleagues of ours from the library's American
Folklife Center have been working in partnership
with colleagues from the Smithsonian
Institution's National Museum
of African American History and Culture, the
one that's going to open in a couple of years,
to gather these interviews
and make them available.
What I really love about this site is that all
of the interviews have transcripts
that are keyword searchable.
And using such resources in the
classroom is really just like bringing
in a guest speaker in so many ways.
If you do a search in the Civil Rights History
Project on individual names, or on locations,
or on specific dates, or just keywords
that, you know, you go through --
you know you've got maybe three whole
days to teach the Civil Rights movement
in a U.S. history class, and you really want
to hit some high points, but you want to do
in a way that is meaningful,
and substantive, and powerful.
These voices are absolutely that.
When I was in the classroom, I used
to love bringing in guest speakers,
and when I look at these interviews,
I just think how extraordinary it is
that these recordings have been made and
that we really can bring these individuals
into our classrooms.
The project, the American Folklife
Center, continually is adding interviews
to this project, and I really -- you know,
I think there's a tendency in so many
of our history classes, where we focus on
-- you know, we all know the big names,
but we don't know the lesser known participants.
That's one of the things I
really appreciate this site,
is some of these people we've heard of, and some
of these people, we've never heard of before,
but the role that they played in
the movement is really significant.
The recordings, Karen, they range.
Some of them are two hours long, and
some of them are much more brief.
That's the thing that I'm saying.
They all have transcriptions
that are keyword searchable.
So if you -- for example, you want to share
with your students a description of things
that happened, you know, in Selma, you
could just simply do a search on Selma,
and it'll narrow down for you those
individuals who speak, you know,
specifically about events in Selma.
So there are ways to widdle
down the amount of time.
Also, in the Articles and Essays section of
the site, some of our colleagues have done some
of that work for us, where they have
told us, "Hey, you might want to listen
to this particular recording
if you're interested in this."
Again, that helps.
Of course, you can always send your students
to these sites, and ask them to find excerpts.
And I guarantee you, they will
get sucked in to listening to more
than simply what they've been assigned to do,
because these recordings
really are very powerful.
It's hard to not continue watching them.
Again, I'm scanning here.
Yes, Pete, you're exactly right.
The American Folklife Center, one of the --
what you're thinking of is the StoryCorps app,
and you may have heard about that on NPR.
The -- I'm happy to tell you about it right now.
The StoryCorps recordings do make their
way to the Library of Congress by way
of the American Folklife Center, and StoryCorps
is encouraging everyone this Thanksgiving
to use their new app and
interview family members
over the Thanksgiving Day dinner
table, and it really is a great idea.
I think I may actually be roping
my parents into doing that,
so I'll just give them a heads-up at some point.
Excellent.
All right.
So back to the topic of these
first-hand accounts.
The Rosa Parks collection came to the Library
of Congress last November, and our colleagues
who work in prints and photographs, and who work
in the manuscript division
have been working really hard
to get these materials processed
and ready for researchers.
Right now the photographs and the
manuscripts are available to researchers
in the reading rooms, and all of
the materials are being digitized.
We did a Summer Teacher Institute this
past summer, focused on civil rights.
And we had hoped that, of course, the whole
collection would have been digitized in time,
and that was a little too ambitious.
But fortunately, we were able to
describe what our real hopes were,
and we were able to get a subset of
the much larger collection available
as a special primary source set.
These materials all come from
the Rosa Parks collection.
This particular letter that
begins -- it's not a letter.
It's a recollection of Rosa Parks about
what happened to her in December of 1955
at the beginning of the Montgomery bus boycott.
And she writes, "I had been pushed around
all my life, and I felt at this moment
that I couldn't take it anymore."
And she goes on and describes what happened.
And it is her first-hand
account, and it just tremendous.
If you go to that particular link, what
you'll get is a small collection of materials
that we identified this summer and used with
our Summer Teacher Institute participants.
They are just a small fraction of what
will ultimately be made available right
around Rosa Parks' birthday
at the beginning of February,
so be on the lookout for
an announcement about that.
Very good.
Oh, and I love the way this
technology works, because, you know,
Cheryl's over there having this great
conversation, and Kristen's sharing ideas.
This is good, very good.
Some more things.
And I know I'm running low on time, so
I'm going to try to speed it up a little.
So I've mentioned our Summer Teacher
Institutes a couple of times during this talk.
These images do a good job of illustrating
some of the elements of all of our institutes.
We try to get our teachers up close
and personal with the collections.
That image at the top are some science teachers
who are pretty much blown
away by primary sources.
And I have to say, I just love that, because
some of you who know me know that I'm trying
to infiltrate science classes with
good history, and we have colleagues
who are absolutely onboard with this effort.
I think, at that moment, our colleague Mark
Dimunation was showing the science teachers a
Galileo item from the rare book collection.
You also see in those images our
teachers working collaboratively,
working on an activity there
that involves some maps.
And we do lots of sharing.
And there are extraordinary opportunities
just to connect with other teachers,
and to learn about the library's resources
and some strategies to use in the classroom.
We learn so much from one another.
I'm going to keep moving.
Okay, so here, here, this
is a teacher last summer.
I love these index cards.
This was another teacher who was describing
what the Summer Teacher Institute experience
and meeting all of these colleagues
from around the institution was like.
She said, "If I could draw an
artichoke, that would be my illustration
of the gallery of presenters today.
Layer after layer of amazing, and we are still
not at the heart of the Library of Congress.
So many layers."
I really like that.
And what's new.
I also want to emphasize that not only
are summer programs for teachers available
from the library in D.C., but year round,
professional development opportunities
are available from our teaching
with Primary Sources partners
around the country.
If you visit loc.gov/teachers/tps.
Or you just click on these
links, because they all work.
[chuckles] You can find out what is
available near you from our 28th Teaching
with Primary Sources consortium partners,
who are located in 17 different states.
Keep in mind that even though there
may not be somebody in your state,
that doesn't mean they won't work with you.
They absolutely will.
There are summer opportunities.
There are during-the-school-year opportunities.
Each one of our partners has website resources,
and many of them do webinars of their own.
There are often videos and other resources
that I encourage you to take advantage of.
This past year, the library received some
sort of surprise funding to make available
through a grant procedure to organizations
who would make online interactive
and mobile apps related to
Congress and civic participation.
We just announced three winners
of those grants last month,
and we're real excited to
see what they come up with.
Their grants will span over a two-year
period, and during those two years --
by the end of the two years, they will have
created apps for use in K to 12 classrooms,
again, that focus on Congress
and civic participation.
One of the grantees, by the
way -- I should announce them.
One of them is at George Mason University.
One is the University of Indiana's
Center for Representative Government.
And the third is Muzzy Lane Software.
And what we were so excited about with
these grantees is that they are all working
in partnership with other organizations that
are really committed to civic education.
So all of them, you know.
Some of them are working with Circle [phonetic].
Some of them are working
with the Center for Civic Ed.
with National History Day.
Some of them are working
with pre-service teachers.
Others are working with pre-service
teachers specifically focused on elementary.
I mean, we just -- we're real excited
about the strength of these proposals
and what we think will come out of them, simply
because there's so many potential partners.
In the same vein of civic
education, congress.gov.
I know lots of you are familiar with
THOMAS, and I know that you know
that congress.gov is replacing
the THOMAS website.
It seems as though every
month or every other month,
our colleagues in our web services division,
they will come up with something
new in congress.gov.
And we will hear about it, and we'll be like,
"Oh, can't wait to tell teachers about this.
This is really neat."
I circled one little section, only because we
often mention it to teachers, and they say, "Oh,
I've been using congress.gov, but
I didn't realize that was here."
So what I have circled on the site is some
videos that are colleagues in the Law Library
and in our web services division have
created related to the legislative process.
So if you're looking for
resources or ways to, you know --
how to approach how a bill becomes
a law, that's another resource.
Congress.gov has a function.
So if you're on the website, and you do a search
on current legislation, and you just do a search
on something like healthcare, or campaign
finance reform, or the environment,
or you're going to pick your subject,
you know, what will come up is a page
that will list all of the current legislation.
And when you select one piece of current
legislation, you can follow that piece
of legislation through the process.
And there's a bill tracker that really
-- and I know this may sound horrible,
but it's really true, and I love it.
It reminds me of the Domino's pizza tracker.
So when a bill is introduced, it tells me
that it's introduced, and then it goes into,
you know, it was introduced in the House.
It passes the House.
It goes to a committee.
It makes its way -- the whole
process is identified,
and if you've got your students
following pieces of legislation,
it's really a terrific resource for that.
When you're on a piece of legislation's site,
you have a terrific encapsulation of that piece
of legislation, a very nice abbreviated
version, a synopsis of the bill, is available.
And another resource that, again, it's new
to congress.gov is now the entire Congressional
record is available through congress.gov,
and you can search the Congressional record,
again, by topic, by date, and so forth.
And we had a couple of our teachers during
the Summer Teacher Institute mentioned
in the Congressional record this summer, and
we all got a kick out of seeing them in there,
and we could use them as an example
of what fascinating information you
can find in the Congressional record.
We have two teachers in residence working with
our team this year, and they are dynamite.
Up on the top right-hand side is Trey Smith.
He's a science teacher from
the Philadelphia area.
And Tom Bober is on the left, and
he is an elementary school librarian
from Clayton, Missouri.
And they are both absolutely terrific.
Tom is focusing his attention
on audio-visual resources,
and Trey is focusing his
attention on science resources.
And we will certainly have another
teacher in residence opportunity
for the 2016/17 school year, and we will make
an announcement about that probably right
around early January, so please be
on the lookout for that announcement.
The library has a new poet laureate.
He has a fabulous effort underway.
His project, "La Case de Colores," invites
all Americans to contribute a verse
to an epic poem about the American experience.
Again, another terrific opportunity,
brand new from the library.
As of, I think, two weeks ago, the
Alan Lomax collection is now available
on the library's website.
This particular object is a piece
of correspondence from Woody Guthrie
to Alan Lomax that caught my eye.
And if you want to continue finding out what's
new at the library, be sure to go to loc.gov,
and on the far left-hand side,
where it says News from the Library,
you can just scan press releases almost on a
daily basis to find out what new collections
and new opportunities are available.
And I see what Marcy is suggesting.
She wants me to see that link again.
Yes, the link for the poet laureate.
If you just go to loc.gov poetry, that'll get
you straight to Juan Felipe Herrera's site
and the "La Case de Colores" opportunity.
And again, this entire presentation will be
available as a recording in just a couple
of days, so you can certainly
come back and refer to it as well.
Finally, we are doing lots of
collaborating at the library.
We have a small staff, but we work very
effectively with partners on the outside
who have very similar missions to our own of
reaching teachers w high-quality resources
and opportunities, including teaching
tolerance and National History Day,
the Civic Renewal Network, Share My Lesson.
And down there, you see National Geographic.
We're going to work with colleagues at
National Geographic on a special issue
of social ed related to teaching
geography with Primary Sources
that we hope you'll be on the lookout for.
>> So thank you everyone for
joining, for participating,
for the lively and wonderful discussion.
Thank you Lee Ann for such a
rich and wonderful speedy tour
through what's new from the Library of Congress.
We have a three-question survey.
The link on the screen is hot, and
I'm pushing it out through the chat.
It does help us shape our programming,
if you could take the time to
answer those three questions.
For completing this session, you have earned
a certificate for one instructional hour,
and look for an email within five business
days with directions to access that.
Thank you so much for joining,
and this session is ended.
Bye bye, everybody.
>> Thanks so much everyone.
This was fun.
I admire your tenacity, sticking with us.
Thanks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us as loc.gov.